i asked my buddy kevin connolly if he
would jump on the show
talk to us a little bit about you know
his entourage
days uh as well as
what he's doing now so let's bring him
to the show right now actor
uh podcast network owner
um whatever you want to call dolphins
fan
and hockey aficionado mr kevin connolly
what's up buddy
how are you thanks for having me on ryan
good morning to you good morning
so um i was telling the guys here about
the victory podcast this was something
you kind of came up with you started a
company called action park media
and in the process doug ellen and kevin
dillon and you
you know decided to to put together you
know you know entourage was such a
huge show uh in the mainstream for so
long
and to kind of bring it back in the eyes
of the fans through
episodic post uh podcast tell us about
that show and and what you're doing with
it right now
well you know it's funny because we're
we're all
you know a little a little bit older so
we're kind of from a different
generation so just
having trying to make don't understand
what a podcast
is what they uh was interesting in
itself and i think that
you know i mean i had been been doing it
for a while but when i approached doug
and kevin about doing it
it's just sort of like well what is what
is it what exactly does it entail so
at first it just kind of started out as
us having fun but it's become real
nostalgic and
you know time flies by so fast that you
blink your eyes and you go
man it was 15 years ago that we shot
that episode so
it really is sort of like podcast dvd
commentary you know we go back
we talk about what we remember uh
filming this episode or or or that
episode
which is also funny because what time
does everybody has a different
memory of certain stories you know but
um
we really have had a blast and it's it's
just kind of exploded
uh and now we're kind of branching out
you know doing interviews we had charlie
sheen on the other day which was uh
which is pretty wild but we're we're
still having fun and as long as you're
having fun doing it
that's uh that's the way to keep it
going because you could burn out on
these things you know
so you know most of our our viewers and
listeners
were huge fans of the show kind of just
take us back to what
what the beginning of that was like and
how quickly it escalated into this
you know this mainstream phenomenon and
where you couldn't you know walk down
the street in la without
you know it was and you filmed in la too
which was crazy all over the place just
kind of tell us about what that was like
to be a part of
when also to remember this goes back to
pre-social media right so there was no
you know instagram and the twitters of
the world were just getting started
uh there was no tmz uh you know
if uh you know somebody wrote a story
about it was in the national enquirer
you know so right
we were you know we were we were like a
little be a little engine
uh that could we we started out as a
small show but at the end of the day we
had the
you know five thousand pound gorilla
which is hbo behind us
uh and and you know they hung in there
with us and and
the show caught on and uh you know you
mentioned la
you know uh la became in the hollywood
area became
uh sort of the sixth character almost
for lack of a
a better term you know people will watch
the show and be like oh my god i eat
there and
people would come to l.a and visit and
you know we really put earth cafe on the
map too bad we didn't have a
little piece of that restaurant you know
yeah for sure yeah i think like the
opening scene
uh of of the show i uh was wasn't it i
would now
that wasn't fred singles that was fred
uh over on melrose over there well i
told you this i told you this the other
day since you know
having met you about a year ago and and
i went back during the pandemic and
rewatched it
and i told the guys on wednesday when we
were going to have you on
that i i've rewatched it and uh um
as a 45 year old man now i i watch it
and i'm like oh my god
these these these individuals aren't
aren't the greatest of people and
aren't telling the the best stories in
fact kevin conley's character is
probably the lead
in this show now with the moral compass
of all this well i mean as a as an adult
and about to be dad
when you see old episodes and sometimes
what do you look at is
just fun or you're like oh i don't i
don't know if that was the best
best uh you know tutelage for young
young adults or not well
for sure i mean you know we you know we
look back and as we're
re-watching these episodes before we
cover them on the podcast
there are these you know cringe-worthy
moments where
kevin and i always have the the benefit
of being able to blame doug
because you know she wrote it the writer
and the creator and did all this kind of
stuff but
you know you know that you know doug
will always say that the truth is
that at the time you know if you look at
a character like ari gold
you know he he would lose his job in 30
seconds for
behaving that way and and in an office
setting but 15 years ago
that's what it was and there did you
know endless
uh examples of that you know and that's
why it would be just different today and
people would say well how would you
reboot that show
and would it look different and the
answer is well of course it would
be different because different world
yeah you know
you know but but it is true you kind of
look back on it and
there are some super uh super
cringe worthy moments but you know it's
hard to
you know it's a bit of a time capsule
and that was
sort of the time so you really can't
live in in the regret
and uh you know yeah this is definitely
things that wouldn't fly
but it's funny to your point also ryan
you know i was
you know when the show aired or
initially like i was like oh this guy's
a party
you know my character was the party
pooper and i was all these things and i
was always killing a good time and now
looking back all these years later it's
like what a great guy he was you know
yeah when on the first run i was the guy
that nobody wanted to invite
to the party so uh it's funny you know
the dynamic shift and uh
but um you know it's also too the the
pandemic is just sort of brought
in a whole new uh audience i mean i you
know i've called
young cousins and these people are like
watching and i'm thinking wow you were
five
right when the show aired and now you've
seen every episode so
um you know i think hbo max has given it
some new life and uh
yeah man it's it's fun taking the trip
down down memory road plus it's at
action park media so finally i get to be
doug's boss and boss him around
yeah i like that uh we're talking to
kevin connolly actor and director
uh owner of action park media tell us a
little bit about that podcasting network
uh
uh kind of incubator you're running and
what what it means and all and all the
great things you're doing
yeah you know like you said it's the the
it's it's an incubator for
sort of ideas and you know um for you
know victory is tricky because the uh
the ultimate underlying rights are owned
by
hbo so there's not really much room for
to take it
out of the podcast base there but you
know you do these you know you do these
podcasts nowadays they turn into
uh at netflix docuseries and then they
become a tv show you know and that's
really
that's really the the goal you know you
do a cool podcast it could become a
movie
a show a documentary there's it the
sky's the limit and it really is
sort of a new medium where people are
are tapping into to get
to get content which is what uh people
need with all these
new outlets uh
this this um day has brought a couple
blockbuster trades and
you being from long island most people
would think you were a jets or a giants
fan but no you
you became a dolphins fan over time and
they
were a part of these big trades i don't
know if you noticed or or heard about it
yet but they
they moved out of the number three spot
so it looks like
they're going to stick with tua how did
you like him in his first year and and
what are you expecting from your
dolphins in in in year two under tua
well you know ryan you you were uh you
were the first guy to
to put that in my head that you've been
i think you've been outspoken about to
uh
no you know you don't think that he's
necessarily the guy you gotta understand
for dolphins fans to finally
have this guy i mean it's great i mean
we'll see
i mean it feels like they have the the
confidence in them and
but most notably about the dolphins what
what has become apparent over the over
the last few years is that
people really like playing for this
coach you know i mean they just like
them
they go the extra mile for them um i i
don't know i like i like i like things i
like the dolphins
uh this year i mean you know buffalo
stuff
but um i like that they held onto two uh
and and who who the dolphins gonna pick
up what what's it looking like what's
the prediction
i trust you you're my go-to football guy
well i i think they they get the they
get the number six overall after a swap
with the eagles so that puts them in
prime territory for
jamar chase wide receiver from lsu or
devonta smith wide receiver from alabama
so i think they're going to go after a
big time
wide receiver class guy and that that's
going to be superb i mean if they re
reunite devante smith with
with two i think that would be pretty
funny i have a question for you though
how does a uh kid from long island
new york become a dolphins fan
oh i have a theory so you know you're my
dad you're supposed to be
a jets fan that's the other thing too
like when you're from long island
they try to tell you what your teams are
supposed to be right you're supposed to
be
mets jets or yankees giants right
and if you're from long island you're
supposed to be mets jets i'm a yankee
dolphin fan now
my brother uh i have an older brother
you know he's seven years older than me
we had bunk beds
he was a dolphin fan in hindsight i
think he just wanted to
have a a problem with my dad
then but that's the only thing i could
make sense out of it and believe me
every year
on the first day of the regular season i
call my brother and say how could you do
this to us
but the flip side is if i were a jets
fan
i wouldn't be much happier right i mean
it's uh no you wouldn't
six of one half dozen of another and and
um yeah so
but i i like them i like them this year
so we'll see this could be
this could be the year and also too i
don't jump teams
right but better or worse i mean i had a
lot of tough years as an islander fan
they're
you're loyal you're loyal in the face of
everything
i don't i don't switch teams okay so so
you know of course i've i've followed
you for years you know
from rocky to to the notebook uh
all of these uh all of these things but
what
really kind of puts you on my map is
when i watched a 30 for 30 that you did
uh on the the crazy story about the
owner of the islanders and how how it
came about and everything that
played into that can you can you fill
our listeners in a little bit about this
story and how this
this uh this documentary came to be
yeah so yeah we you know it was a 30 for
30 was called big shot
and um you know listen i don't think
it's any secret hockey you know
at times it's not something that
everybody uh wants to talk about
on sports radio or whatever it is you
know it's uh
it you know espn had had only done one
other hockey 30 for 30 and that was
called king's ransom about the gretzky
trade
but this really was a a a business story
with a with a hockey background and it's
about a guy
that um essentially in the in the days
of you know the early 90s with
the banks just giving away money it's
about a guy who
with a fake fax borrowed 85 million
dollars
from fleet bank of boston and purchased
the new york islanders
and he somehow slipped through the
cracks because he ran
in the right circles now this story
changed
the vetting process for all the sports
it happened to happen
uh in hockey but it changed the way they
vet
every owner and um this guy actually was
in the driver's seat of a team
for four months and it finally one day
somebody turned around and said wait
who is this guy no they
threw him in jail but but it's funny
this guy takes him he fired the coach
he traded a couple guys he's flying
around on the team plane
and he has zero dollars to his name and
um
you know but he said you know uh you
know was the best four months of his
life
you know so it was a pretty wild story
um
he's quite a character and and the
ironic thing that he ended up back in
jail when the movie came out
which you know obviously wasn't my
intention but um yeah he's just a
a professional con man and uh you know
in the fake it till you make it
um he mastered that so it's pretty cool
and like i said i would always tell
people you don't have to be a hockey fan
to enjoy that one go watch it because
it's really cool no i i recommend it to
anybody out there who are fans of those
types of documentaries 30 for 30s espn
it's great so you and i were talking
yesterday uh
uh you know when i was making the turn
and you were about to set off in that
cold
cold ass weather we played in yesterday
morning um
uh about knowing tj jefferson and
uh a little story you guys had so i'm
gonna i'm gonna pass it off to tj here
and you guys can have a little
conversation all right
what's up man i you know ever i think i
think about it often do you want to take
the leave are you well
you take the lead on this all right i'll
take the lead on this so kevin and i you
know this happened back i believe was
2007.
whoa yeah so this was a long time ago
and you know as i've told kevin
throughout the years we don't see each
other often but you know it's always
like
mad respect and love when i do see him
and i was kind of living in an entourage
situation
myself where i was ashton kutcher's
roommate and so it was hard for me to
like
my friends back in pittsburgh for me to
try to explain to them
what life it turned into out here until
entourage came on and i was like you see
this
this is kind of what's going on out here
but in this particular day man it was uh
there was a club
called area in los angeles down in la
cienega
and so the story goes and i'm gonna cut
some of this out because
you know we'll save that for another
time but ashton calls me and he's like
what are you doing i happen to be by the
beverly center this night
told him where i was he goes we're going
the area and i'm like cool i'm right
down the street
so me being cheap i didn't want to valet
this car now i have to tell you guys
this this car i was in was wilmer
valderrama's escalade if you've ever
seen punk
the punk episode where his car got
destroyed
i was in this car i borrowed it because
my car had broken down and wilmer was
out of town so
i borrow his escalade and instead of
going to park valet i decide
right next to trashy lingerie on los
cienega
was this street light it was the
brightest street light i've ever seen in
my life like the sun didn't
shine as bright as it was over there and
also to tj give yourself a little credit
if you can find a spot on the street and
avoid the valet at a club like that
it's a better place on a thursday night
you know so
i parked right next to trashy lingerie
under this bright street light
so we go the area then uh let's just say
we went to another club
and we went to this other club for a
while and on the way back
ashton had a car so he's driving us and
kevin goes hey there's a party in the
hills
do you want to come and i'm like yeah
let's do it i said i'll drive
so ashton's car drops us off at wilmer's
car
and kevin and i go to the car and i hit
the alarm to unlock it okay and i opened
up the door
and when i tell you that you know
sometimes you stare at something or
whatever you're staring at it's pretty
obvious like i'm staring at mike deltuva
right now
but i opened the car door and what i saw
like a thousand things went through my
head because
the steering column but you were also
very quiet now i don't know anything
i'm just like you're just waiting to get
into the passenger door and i
opened the door and someone had taken a
screwdriver
went through the ignition the lock on
the door they had ripped the steering
column out and we i
supplied don bowie with some pictures of
this last night in case this came up
they ripped the steering column out they
jammed the screwdriver into the ignition
i mean
and i opened the door and i looked at
this and i was like
is this my car like did this happen and
kevin's like bro is this your car
no this is wilmer's car and like you
know
what happened is somebody tried to car
jacket but in my mind i was like was it
like that when i drove here
like all this stuff going through my
mind and i'm like oh my god no like
someone tried to steal this car and
kevin's like is this yours i'm like bro
this isn't even my car so i had to call
ashton up
ashton comes back kevin hopson ashton's
car and kevin goes to the party
so me and kutcher kutcher and i are
sitting outside of trashy lingerie it's
3 30 in the morning and the cops come
right
so the cops come and they're looking at
the paper for the car and they realize
this is wilmer valderrama's car
why do you have it and i'm trying to
explain them that i'm friends with
wilmer and blah blah blah but
you know that's not going to fly and
luckily ashton was just sitting
a picture right here he was just sitting
on the sidewalk
and the cops happen to look at him and
he nudges the other coffee goes look
he goes what is this a punk and then the
cops all start laughing and joking with
ashton
but meanwhile i'm sweating because i
took wilmer's car
and i didn't ask for it and wilmer was
out of town he was in new york so the
cops are all like
laughing and joking with ashton kevin
took off
i'm sweating like what am i going to do
i got to tell this dude so it was 300
bucks
to tow wilmer's car back to his house i
had to call him in new york the next
morning go hey bro um
i took your car i i borrowed your car
because it got broken he told me i could
borrow it on wednesday he didn't tell me
i could borrow it on thursday but i took
it anyway on thursday
and wilmer and i will never forget this
we had like a 15-minute phone
conversation and
four minutes was him yelling at me like
bro why didn't you violate it why'd you
park on the street and then after that
after he got it out he was like all
right cool bro so i'll be home on
saturday
let's go out let's see you know let's
get dinner when i get back in and that's
how cool wilmer is he kind of like
he got mad for a second and i was like
humbled
himself and expressed himself but that's
kevin and i that's the story every time
we see each other we talk about this
time
and kevin was just the best he was just
like i got to save my side i got to say
my
part right so first of all
in hindsight whoever did that knew what
they were doing
to take it even a step further we
probably walked up on them which is
scary
at the same time right yeah they knew
what they were doing that
column was gone they were in there who
knows maybe
maybe they heard us coming and they ran
away but i can remember
you should i have this image in my head
if you're sitting
in the car with your hands on the
steering wheel and you're just staring
straight ahead
trying to figure out is this the right
car
i don't remember the car being like this
and i'm thinking like
yeah maybe he's embarrassed his car is a
mess
hey listen my girlfriend's car looks
like that nobody tried to steal it
but you're just and then you look at me
and you're like i think somebody tried
to steal the car and i'm like that's all
right man you know cars get messy
sometimes it's no big deal
i just thought you had a cracked
steering wheel bro i really but
this was a professional job i mean they
they were in and out of there and then
yeah i remember
standing on the street like waiting for
the cops and i'm like
i don't know if a buddy of mine might
call that i just like jumped
but i did call you later on ago how'd it
go
but every time i i see that i think
about that and in yemen i
think that was 14 years ago wow how was
that party by the way
what's that how was that party by the
way
the good news is the highlight of the
night was the steering wheel
that's the that's the kind of stuff i
didn't know until right now that it was
wilbur's car
oh that's awesome that's awesome
that's an awesome part of it i like the
entourage you talk about the entourage
moment right like that's what it is oh
hey by the way wilmer
uh sorry i took your car last night and
by the way somebody tried to steal it
that sounds like some turtle would have
done that sounds like something turtle
would have done
kevin connolly everybody actor director
uh
uh he's become a good friend too that's
that's pretty cool about all this
um we're gonna we're gonna do some we're
gonna do some stuff together here in the
next year and have a lot of fun so i
appreciate you joining the show buddy
have a great day
go dolphins much it guys let's tee it up
good talk to you kev
all right i'll talk to you later guys
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here